in the days of hashtag me too and
hashtag no means no and politicians and
media moguls dropping left and right for
sexual coercion consent has taken center
stage as the indispensable prerequisite
for mutual action unless of course that
means a confectioner declines to
participate in a gay wedding ceremony in
which case he must be stripped of his
First Amendment rights and he'll do it
and he'll like it baby just relax and
enjoy it we will discuss masterpiece
cake shop the Supreme Court and why no
only means no until ashtag Love Wins
then roaming millennial on amber Athey
joined the panel of deplorable z' to
discuss what the resignation of John
Conyers tells us about democrat strategy
the Supreme Court's upholding of trumps
travel ban and the joyful post michelle
obama return of 1% chocolate milk to
school lunches i'm michael knowles and
this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Supreme Court is hearing oral
arguments on masterpiece cake shop the
Colorado Civil Rights Commission this is
the famous Christian Baker gay wedding
case that you've heard about for years
if the Supreme Court hasn't totally
given itself over to nonsense on the
First Amendment the Baker Jack Phillips
will win this case and there is actually
good reason to be hopeful for free
speech and religious liberty here this
Supreme Court has been generally
excellent on First Amendment issues
Citizens United obviously the fear is
that Anthony Kennedy showed us in the
aubergine that when it comes to gay
marriage he stops thinking like a lawyer
and starts writing like a lyrical 19th
century poet in that case he found a
right to intimacy somewhere in the
Constitution which seems that it doesn't
jibe that well with the hashtag need to
climb it doesn't if there were a
constitutional right to intimacy then
Harvey Weinstein would get off scot-free
Kevin Spacey Al Franken Roy Moore even
he'd be seated immediately the right to
intimacy is obviously ridiculous
I think Scalia said at the time that the
right to intimacy isn't found in
marriage also by the way ask the nearest
hippie how I miss that man it's
ridiculous but that said the courts
swing vote Justice Kennedy has been
pretty good on free speech so we'll see
where he falls here religious liberty
and free speech by the way would not
have had a shot of winning the day had
President Trump not won the presidency
and appointed Neil Gorsuch to the bench
if Hillary had won this case would be
over already we wouldn't be talking
about it so thank you to America for
electing Donald Trump and also to Mitch
McConnell who doesn't get enough credit
for this Mitch McConnell staved off the
Democrat hordes who were clamoring to
put Merrick garland on the bench just
after Justice Scalia died so to the
merits of the case there's a lot of fake
news out there so let's break down what
we know in 2012 before Colorado
redefined marriage to include monogamous
same-sex unions a Colorado gay couple
Charlie Craig and David Mullins ordered
a custom wedding cake from Jack
Phillips's boutique masterpiece cake
shop Phillips a devoted Christian
declined to the order because his
religious beliefs prevented him from
participating in it by lending his
artistic services to gay
Ceremonies his religious beliefs also
prevent him from making custom cakes for
lewd bachelor parties divorce parties
and Halloween he won't make a custom
cake for Halloween
those are his bullet religious beliefs
this is his artistic cake shop the
couple he explained was free to choose
from any of the generic cakes for their
ceremony but he wouldn't create a custom
piece for the event so what happened
Craig and Mullins went to one of the
other countless cake shops and they got
their cake made for their ceremony there
are apparently plenty of cake shops that
are willing to bake cakes for gay
wedding ceremony we're anticipating
probably a 30% boost in revenue this
year from gay wedding cakes alone 30%
boost yeah there are all these new
ceremonies every other cake shop is
willing to do it some people are owned
by devoted Christians or Muslims or
whatever and they have these religious
beliefs and they don't want to
participate in the wedding and lend
their artistic expression to it problem
solved right apparently not because
Craig and Mullins decided to make it
their mission to force Phillips to craft
the gay marriage cake or else to shut
down his store to lose all his business
they filed a complaint with the Colorado
Civil Rights Commission they claimed
discrimination the case has now made it
all the way up to the Supreme Court and
they just heard oral arguments this
morning we should make this point very
clear this case has very little to do
with gay marriage there's very little to
do with gay marriage per se Gavin
McGinnis said he used to support gay
marriage until he realized that it was
mostly a political act to screw with
Christians and cases like this or where
Gavin got that idea from George will -
by the way thinks the Supreme Court
should side with the state and make
Philips craft the cake a lot of
conservatives that this is the
conservatives who are like conservatives
but not that kind of conservative you
know the ones or I'm a Republican but I
don't like any Republican stuff they
they insist it doesn't matter who cares
it's just a cake it's so trippy 'it's
just just make the cake the left is
obviously making the same point lagoons
are terrified of gay wedding cakes for
some reason
they say people can't help who or what
they fear but let's be honest being
afraid of a gay wedding cake is a choice
all they're afraid isn't that they're
just afraid you silly pee but so it
doesn't matter well okay if it doesn't
matter then drop the complaint it
doesn't matter right it doesn't matter
it's a silly case okay good then you
back down if you've been the other side
in the culture working back down they
drop the suit if it doesn't matter just
go to another cake shop actually the
couple did go to another cake shop but
they know that the cake matters the cake
does matter because it's a symbol and
it's a mechanism of coercion who gets to
decide how you use your artistic talents
you your conscience or the government
who gets to decide which messages are
optional and which or compulsory George
Will is either being obtuse here or is
missing the point he claimed in his
column on the subject that the primary
purpose of cake is to be eaten sure
right that's the primary purpose of cake
but wedding cake is a different than
regular old cake that's why regular old
cake costs eleven dollars and wedding
cakes cost into the thousands of dollars
I know this now I'm looking at wedding
cakes nobody has turned me down yet
because my money is green as Princeton
professor Robbie George rightly points
out in today's New York Times a former
newspaper wedding cakes are the
centerpieces of weddings and they
symbolize an idea that's why we have
them that's why we don't just only serve
cannoli or something or doughnuts at
weddings we had there are wedding cakes
they symbolize an idea namely that a
wedding has taken place that a marriage
has begun some people don't believe that
that is the case when it comes to
same-sex monogamous unions the state has
no right to force an individual into an
expressing an idea with which he
disagrees even if that idea has been
adopted as the official state line as of
like five minutes ago but this is the
other aspect of insanity in this case
until the day before yesterday nobody
would have fathomed redefining marriage
to include same-sex unions now that
which is not forbidden is compulsory and
by that light it's not so bizarre that
this whole case which is really about
compulsion and free speech it centers on
whether or not an individual is required
by law to express so recent so utterly
novel and ideas gay marriage it isn't
about gay marriage it's about the state
and the culture warrior left flexing its
muscles and
individual liberty and conscience into
submission so some some claim that our
ruling in favor of religious liberty and
free speech a ruling in favor of
masterpiece cake shop and Jack Phillips
that will destroy all sorts of
anti-discrimination legislation in the
country but there is no evidence for
that as the cake shops lawyers Phillips
himself have made clear the custom cake
is an artistic piece that clearly comes
along with free artistic and
philosophical expression that's why
they're so expensive that's why the
bakery is called a masterpiece cake shop
it's not called commodity cake shop or
food cake shop or regular ol $10 gig job
it's a masterpiece it involves artistic
expression by the way it is also ironic
that the left which is degraded and
deconstructed art so much that now you
know a tricycle on top of a newspaper is
art or a giant block in a park or a
smear of color on a wall that sort of
thing now those people are telling us
that confections delicately crafted to
be exhibited at the centerpiece of
wedding ceremonies masterpieces those
are not art but that is neither here nor
there the point is that it isn't
discrimination it isn't that the artists
can choose which customers he will serve
if hopefully the Supreme Court rules in
favor of religious liberty here it's not
that the the artist can say I'm gonna
sell to you but not sell to you the
artist has to sell cakes to everybody as
he repeatedly offered to do in this case
the portrait photographer has to take
photos of everybody the painter has to
paint paintings of everybody but these
artists don't need to convey ideas with
which they disagree a Christian painter
a Christian painter is not required by
law to paint an image of Satan's
stomping on the head of Christ a
Christian photographer is not required
by law or the Constitution to recreate
the piss Christ consider the reverse
actually did to drive the point home
with not-so-subtle a brush there's an
evangelical pastor named Joshua
Fierstein I think he called an a
florida-based bakery that calls itself
LGBT friendly he called it up and
ordered a cake decorated with the phrase
quote we do not support gay marriage now
as you might expect it as Fierstein
expected the bakery hung up that's
entirely their right they didn't want to
express that idea with their art
they have every right moral and
constitutional to refuse to express
certain ideas in art anti-discrimination
laws entitle you to an artist's products
but not to their creativity the left now
insists on this schizophrenic argument
freedom of choice and consent are the
essential prerequisites a modern life
until you contradict their ever-changing
wertha doxy because hashtag me to only
matters until hashtag love wins
speaking of hashtag love wins we will
now bring on our all lady lovely panel
of deplorable z-- today roaming
millennial and amber Athey roaming does
this matter or am I just an insane
culture warrior
I think this absolutely matters and this
story and others like it that we've seen
always bother me and they frustrate me
every time they're brought up and you
know what like you said I think this is
absolutely freedom of religion and it's
a freedom of speech issue but I'm gonna
go further than that in this debate
despite these anti-discrimination law
that exists I don't believe that small
business owners should be compelled to
give their services to anybody they
don't want to for whatever reason I
believe that if you're in the
marketplace if you own your business and
you know you're your own employer you
should absolutely have the right to
refuse service to anyone for any reason
and if people don't like that they're
free to take their business elsewhere to
me this is a question of you know a big
government and keeping the hold of our
rights in the marketplace well you know
this is an aspect of the Civil Rights
Act that muddled the conversation on
this of course which is that you no
longer can refuse service to people just
because you don't like the look of their
jib or something and the question is how
far can you take that I mean is there
any shot that we would return it to a
time when I could walk into a restaurant
they would say I'm sorry we don't serve
anybody who even vaguely reminds me of
Rachel Maddow here or you know are we
going to have to construct some more
complicated less clear version of
freedom of expression and you know
freedom of Commerce given the 1960s I
mean even even in light of America's
past I don't think that the fact that
prejudices existed in a widespread
manner 50 years ago means that we should
have laws that are unconscious
and limit the freedom of business owners
now if you know if someone does have a
rule that they don't want to serve
rachel maddow looking customers it's
even to think about it a silver thing
right but you're allowed to go somewhere
else and you're allowed to tell people
hey this is what this person is doing do
not give them their business why do we
want to fund the businesses of bigots in
any case I would rather know who they
are so I can go and shop somewhere else
that's the irony as it is people tilting
at windmills probably wasn't the case in
the 1960s but these days if you had some
racist shop owner you would be run out
of town on a rail it just the culture
has changed so dramatically since then
now amber who is going to win it seems
to me this all comes down to Anthony
Kennedy is the Baker going to win or his
big oppressive coercive government I
actually think this is towards the Baker
because there was a discrimination case
at a Denver area bakery where that Baker
refused to make cakes for traditional
marriages and the Diversity Commission
ruled there that they excuse me the
diversity Discrimination Commission
ruled there that it was not
discrimination against that person's
Christian beliefs for a baker to refuse
to make a cake for a traditional wedding
well this happened in three cases
apparently in Denver so they it's it's
only discrimination when you're
discriminating against the politically
correct class but when it's the
politically incorrect class it isn't
discrimination but how is the Supreme
Court control well they definitely seem
sympathetic to the fact that in the role
reversals it was not considered
discrimination reading through a lot of
the arguments today they seem to be
grappling with the idea that art is free
speech and to what extent can the
government compel someone to provide a
service and how does that infringe on
their art so basically all the things
that you talked about in your monologue
the thing that really bothers me about
this issue is as roaming millennials
said if someone is willing to
discriminate against you why would you
want to give them your business anyway
why would you want to then turn around
and give them your money after you just
found out the only reason that they're
willing to provide you with that cake is
because
the government is forcing them to do so
I mean let's say you go to a restaurant
and you have the absolute worst service
of your life your waiter comes in they
spill water on you your food is terrible
and then at the end of the meal your
waiter says well we're gonna give you a
gift certificate so you can come back
and eat here again instead of comping
your meal I mean what person their right
mind would want to go back to that
restaurant now free meal I don't know
man and it depends how terrible the
service was I guess but you you make an
excellent point and and it also sounds
like a setup I mean these guys went
there they ordered the cake the cakes
the Baker said no I I can't do that I
won't make your Halloween cake either
and they went they got a cake at any of
the gazillion other bakeries that would
make a custom gay wedding cake but
they've made it their mission to destroy
this guy's life
roaming was it all a setup I I think so
I think this is absolutely politically
motivated I think that they're trying to
prove prove an ideological point here
that goes beyond the plight of just
looking for a wedding cake they've
absolutely made this a political issue
and I really hope that you regardless of
whether you're Christian or not and you
know personally I'm Christian and I I
wouldn't have a problem with the cake
thing but regardless of how you feel
about that specific issue this is just
about being compelled to do something
that you don't believe in and to express
an idea they don't believe it yep right
and I think that's something that
everybody should be able to get behind
whether you're you know Christian and
atheist whether you're conservative or
liberal and you know steven crowder
who's on youtube I'm a big fan of his
he's done an experiment before where
he's actually gone in to Muslim bakeries
and asked for for gay wedding cakes to
be made and guess what they're not crazy
about the idea either but you don't so
many lawsuits against them because it's
not a popular thing to talk about he
rarely saw there than Crowder who's out
of his mind and it's like the last
journalist in America but other than him
they you never see people going into
Muslim bakeries you don't see people
going into Jewish kosher bakeries it
seems to always be these Christian
bakeries I wonder why that is so I am
going to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube but before I do that I have got
to tell you folks our third episode of
the conversation is coming up on Tuesday
December 12th at 5 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m.
Pacific
featuring the one and only
ben shapiro the bossman himself
the slayer of leftist snowflakes so
subscribe today to be a part of the
conversation and ask ben live questions
which he will answer for everyone to
hear
now Ben's episode of the conversation
will stream live on the Ben Shapiro
Facebook page and The Daily wire YouTube
channel and it will be free for everyone
to watch but only subscribers can ask
the questions to ask a question as a
subscriber log in to our website daily
wire comm head over to the conversation
page to watch the live stream after that
just start typing into the daily wired
chat box where Ben will answer questions
in the order they are entered into the
live feed for an entire hour once again
subscribe to get your questions answered
by Ben Tuesday December 12th 5:00 p.m.
Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific to join the
conversation now while you're over there
what else are you gonna get if you
subscribe if you get an annual
membership that's just a hundred dollars
a year it's ten dollars a month or
annual is a hundred dollars a year you
get me you get the under Clavin show you
get the Ben Shapiro show blah blah blah
but you get the leftist here's tumblr
folks this is going to be very important
especially depending on what the Supreme
Court does in this this important case
so if those cakes are allowed to be made
with artistic freedom of choice you are
going to need this to collect all of the
salty runoff go to daily wire.com to do
that before we say goodbye I do need to
thank one of our sponsors they help keep
coffe fa all in our cup they help keep
the lights on they have they've helped
us to decorate with all of this lovely
Christmas decorations and the hashtag me
- mistletoe back there so we have to
talk about policy genius this this
actually matters I people may not have
run into dealing with life insurance
before or the absence of life insurance
it's really important if you're an adult
especially one with kids you know that
you need it but it's so easy to put off
now shopping for life insurance is
confusing it takes forever I I really
didn't do it until someone spelled it
out for me and very often you have to
speak to an agent just to get a quote
policy genius lets you skip all of that
it lets you compare life insurance from
the top providers online it takes as
little as five minutes I am a millennial
I don't do anything that takes longer
than five minutes and you can't do it
online
so if you're busy one minute per day for
five days 30 seconds per day for
somewhere between nine and 11 days if
you find a policy you like and you want
to know more you can talk to any one of
their licensed experts me I don't enjoy
talking to people when Marshall starts
speaking to me even in the earbud or
after the show I just stone-faced right
haven't even look at him
but if you're just browsing you don't
have to talk to anyone that's what I
really enjoy browse away they also don't
just do life insurance you can get
disability insurance renter's insurance
pet insurance you can compare health
insurance I know what you're thinking
you're thinking I'll put off life
insurance it doesn't matter it really
matters it can seriously affect your
family don't be stupid just do it it
doesn't take very long and it's pretty
inexpensive if you need life insurance
but you're putting it off try policy
genius compare it online on your own
terms in your own time policy genius.com
because you should only be forced to
speak to an agent if you've committed a
federal crime and I should never be
forced to speak to Marshall
so that go over to policy genius and and
also go to daily wire.com if you want to
watch the rest of the show that's the
only way you're gonna hear from the
lovely brilliant all-female panel of
deplorable - amber Athey and Rowing
millennial we'll be right back daily
we're calm
I am pretty surprised that Democrats
went this far john conyers the
longest-serving Democrat wrapped the
longest-serving rep period in the House
of Representatives he's been there since
the Johnson administration he has
resigned because of sexual assault and
sexual harassment allegations he has had
pressure from his colleagues all the way
right up to Nancy Pelosi amber are they
gearing up to go after what is this
about why are they throwing other than
this guy's old and desiccated and of no
use to them anymore why are they going
after him there are a couple of things
at play here so first of all Democrats
have been hammered by the right for
going after Roy Moore and Donald Trump
because they haven't been taking care of
the own harrasses in their own house at
the same time though it's very
politically expedient to get rid of John
Conyers because now he's calling for he
endorsed his son today endorse aside and
then it's grandnephew is also running
for the seat so not only are they going
to replace Conyers with another Democrat
they're going to replace Conyers with
probably one of his own family members I
mean we saw Democrats do the exact same
thing during the trial of Senator Bob
Menendez they were asked repeatedly if
he should resign if convicted and they
refused to say because guess what Chris
Christie was still governor of New
Jersey so they were worried that if they
came out and told him to resign if
convicted he would have to resign when
Christie was in a position to replace
him with another Republican senator so
in my opinion they don't really deserve
that much credit for calling for Conyers
to resign because this is just pretty
much political expediency and it's
always nice to see people keep the
family in the family business you know
the public business the people's
business roaming there we've heard
whispers throughout the campaign and so
on about all of the women who are
alleging misconduct by Donald Trump and
it kind of disappeared it didn't really
go anywhere some of it appears to have
been discredited but not all of it is
that what they're saying now we're
willing to throw out this old guy who
doesn't mean anything anymore we're
willing to throw him out and trade him
so that we can finally go after Donald
try
is that the strategy we're gonna see I
think it's absolutely the strategy and
not only are we seeing the Democrats
kind of throw Conyers under the bus so
we're also seeing them do that in in a
large part to Bill Clinton as well
because he's no longer politically
useful so it's very convenient for them
to say oh look now we're all of a sudden
the party that actually cares about
these sexual harassment allegations one
of the people in in their party that are
facing these charges not even charges
these rumors I mean nothing I've seen
has I would think be enough to convict
anybody but when we look at what the
Republicans are facing it's a little bit
more difficult and I think they're
absolutely gearing up to start on the
allegations against Trump again and I
think what also doesn't help Republicans
case is that all although Nancy Pelosi
originally kind of stood by color saying
describing him as what what an idol or
Jude she did the tort turn about really
really fast saying that he should resign
contrast that to how we have from
handling Roy Moore right now he's
actually come out and said yeah this
this guy he should he should definitely
be voted in and I understand why the
Republicans might think it's important
to at least get some Republican in and
Alabama but if we look at the larger the
larger picture it doesn't look good for
the Republican case of yeah we're not
rapey frankly right and obviously in the
case of Roy Moore his opponent Doug
Jones does support fourth trimester
abortions so it gets complicated on that
political issue as well not to say
nothing of the Senate majority we see
these figures coming up 2018 2020
there's talk that they'll nominate
Kamala Harris or she'll be a real
contender so you can see it building
toward this campaign this hashtag me to
campaign that is totally fact free it
looks like the economy might do quite
well under Trump looks like he's doing
an able handling of Foreign Affairs so
they're gonna have to make it all this
feelings based me to stuff are there any
credible allegations against Trump I'm
not saying that there are there Orrin
but are there any allegations that we
see they're gonna jump to the fore and
be the ones that they're gonna smack him
with either roaming or amber I'm not
really sure to be perfectly honest with
you because the ones that were brought
up during the election obviously we're
pretty much brushed aside so I find it
somewhat hard to believe that they would
necessarily be relitigated to the point
that people would find them more
credible in 2020 than they did in 2016
that being said one of the cases is in a
lawsuit right now so we'll see what
happens with that but I just don't think
that people are going to want to dredge
it back up now that they pretty much
already decided that they're okay with
overlooking that to put Trump into
office it's unlikely that that's going
to become a major issue again they've
already dealt with this they've already
made their opinion on this that's a good
point and they can always use the
Clinton excuse up oh it's old news
so well it's only old news cuz you
stalled for 10 years and now you made it
olden yeah that's old news come on stop
don't talk about it other news from the
Supreme Court the Supreme Court has
upheld
President Donald Trump's travel ban from
six muslim-majority countries now this
is being portrayed as the end of the
world the end of America even if America
didn't already end with the tax cuts now
as a devil is really the end of America
but ironically Barack Obama also
restricted travel from precisely the
same countries in during his presidency
roaming you might have seen this you're
on Twitter all the time you're always
tweeting there was this trending hashtag
hashtag no Muslim ban ever is this a
Muslim ban this is absolutely not a
Muslim ban and if it is a Muslim ban
it's one of the least effective Muslim
bans that you could design you know the
largest Muslim countries places like
Indonesia there they're not on the list
this doesn't affect Muslims who aren't
from the areas that were highlighted of
concern you know places like Iran would
be and stuff like that so if it doesn't
affect Muslims who aren't in those
countries and most Muslims aren't in
those countries I feel like you have to
really reach to call it a Muslim ban is
it obviously I saw some statistic that
only one of the countries on the list is
in the top 10 most populous Muslim
countries in the world and
none are in the top five so you're
absolutely right this is not a Muslim
ban but amber is it is it genuine
ignorant or are they just being obtuse
when they flip their lids over president
Trump's travel restrictions but they
probably didn't even know that Barack
Obama imposed travel restrictions is
that comparison legitimate and why
didn't the Democrats freak out at the
time well it's it's such an obvious
political play and I mean let's not kid
ourselves all politicians are hypocrites
so it's not really that surprising
it's easy well it's easy rhetoric right
so like Democrats can say that Trump is
bigoted towards Muslims and then when
the tax reform bill passes they can say
that tens of thousands of people are
going to die it's this really aggressive
ramped up rhetoric that's somehow people
buy into because I mean most people
don't want to die I would guess but it's
it's really transparent as Romig said
this isn't a Muslim band this is about
protecting American sovereignty and also
making sure that people are coming into
the country properly vetted and the
countries that are on this ban list
apparently do not properly vet their
citizens
so I mean Democrats can play this game
but the Supreme Court just ruled in
favor of Trump so they've pretty much
already lost here love it
I also love that we have Neil Gorsuch on
the court because if if Hillary Clinton
won all of these decisions that were
just dancing khofifah about wouldn't
happen baby would not happen so on to
the most important I'm sorry I Roman go
ahead that was that was higher than I
thought it would be actually it's
because Elena Kagan is smart it was
Ginsburg and Sotomayor dissented but
Elena Kagan sided with the conservative
you know we could the Conservatives see
they're not all in all not all
conservative but apparently Antonin
Scalia asked David Axelrod when that
first nomination came up during the
Obama years the one that eventually went
to Sonia Sotomayor he said listen I'm
under no misconception that you're gonna
send someone who agrees with me on the
Constitution but at least send us
somebody smart not to put too fine a
point on it send
elena kagan whom he knew socially and I
suppose professionally and they sent
Sotomayor who is not smart at all and
then later on he got Kagan so it is nice
to see that she can have some
seriousness of purpose and she isn't
just a lefty hack on the court there is
a much more important story than any of
these we you know we're talking about
coercion the government the travel ban
foreign policy forget that 1% chocolate
milk Michelle Obama's tyrannical policy
of banning 1% chocolate milk from school
lunches has wonderfully been overturned
by Donald Trump's Department of
Agriculture little boys and girls
everywhere can now drink 1% chocolate
milk at lunch I'm sure they're very
happy about this roaming this again
seems like a trivial issue who cares if
the kids have chocolate milk but does it
send an important message and isn't
materially significant that this
administration is giving people even
down to little kiddies even maybe chubby
little kids is giving them choice and
giving school districts choice over what
they serve those children I think this
is absolutely an important issue and as
someone who's you know no longer in
school no longer facing these school
lunches it may not affect me personally
but I saw some of the lunches that were
presented under Michelle Obama's
initiative and I'm sure we all saw how
unsatisfying you know just not enough
calories unpleasant to look at
so I think this is absolutely a step in
the right direction and childhood
obesity it's not something to be laughed
at it's absolutely a serious issue but I
think really it's something that needs
to be tackled at the home at the home
level it's not something that we can
just you know big government fix at in
schools see what eight hours a day you
might have kids and even then we don't
have them during the summer so to try
and fix something that's so dependent on
family intervention at the government
level like childhood obesity it was
never gonna work in the first place
mm-hmm and you bring up this point it's
nothing to be laughed at that it's funny
because I think for the photo I don't
remember I think we selected a silly
photo of a fat child but it's
occasionally to be laughed at but it is
a serious issue and that's the point
transgenderism is is actually not to be
laughed at
people who suffer from this illness
obviously drag queens can be kind of
funny but trans gender dysphoria is
nothing to be laughed at but it isn't
the pressing issue of the federal
government Antonin Scalia went I got to
meet him one time we asked about these
questions and he said not everything
that is hateful or odious is covered by
some provision of the Constitution we
don't need the federal government to go
in and invade every aspect of our lives
and run our lives for us little kids can
choose their own chocolate milk there
was this issue I think Michelle Bachman
was the champion of it the light bulb of
freedom of choice Act because after Al
Gore's stupid movie they made us use all
those hideous fluorescent light bulbs
that destroyed the lighting quality of
our home and poisoned us with mercury
and they banned all of the good language
yeah they were expensive and they banned
all the good ones that burned all of the
energy and looks really warm and nice
Michelle Bachman came back and said
here's the light bulb freedom of choice
Act and they all mocked her they said
wow then what a stupid issue if it's a
stupid issue then you back off why do I
have to why is it a stupid issue when I
want to hold my side of it and the side
of freedom and choice but it's not a
stupid issue when you pass legislation
to limit what kind of light bulb that I
can have amber we're talking about these
cultural battles meanwhile Donald Trump
is reforming taxes he's packing the
courts he's backing the courts of good
originalist justices he's deregulating
at the federal level is this
administration going to be a culture war
administration as many have thought or
is the culture war just distracting from
the economic focus of the administration
how are we going to look back on Trump
it still remains to be seen we're still
waiting on the full repeal and replace
of Obamacare so we'll see what happens
with that but I think this is definitely
a great start I personally I kind of
love the cultural battles I think this
milk story is amazing I was on free
lunches for a couple of years back when
I was in middle school and let me tell
you when you have a school lunch in
front of you that has charred pizza and
brown lettuce you are really really
grateful for that carton of chocolate
milk which by the way is only about like
150 calories per carton and is really
good post-workout so Michelle Obama and
her like nutrition guideline
need to just go somewhere else I'll have
to remember that I am shedding for the
wedding so chocolate milk will go on the
list of things that I am a electrolytes
after you workout that's very important
and they are symbols a lot of times
people say well this is it's just
semantics especially with gay marriage
you say you're just arguing over
semantics semantics means meaning it
means meaning we're arguing over symbols
because we're arguing over the
symbolized now you bring up Obamacare
just on this point I'm still so happy
I'm still dancing cough fi over tax
reform the tax reform did something that
we didn't quite expect it repealed the
Obamacare mandate in the Senate that
might make it to the final bill which
seems to set the stage it creates so
much political pressure to now repeal
all of the Obamacare regulations and
reform all of those health care
regulations it also might set the stage
for entitlement reform that's a Rubio
and Ryan or both saying roaming are we
gonna am I just having a fever dream
right now
am I just exploding out of my head or is
it possible that we're going to get all
of these legislative goals like health
care like entitlement reform that we
thought were impossible with Trump well
I would like to say that it's possible I
mean if there's ever a time that I would
be possible it should be now Republicans
have both houses they have the White
House I say let's do this but you know
you of course still have those people
who shall remain nameless but our John
McCain committed to holding things back
and I really I really think that you
know that if Stitch 'when s' look look
up how your representatives are voting
please look up how your Senators are
voting and if they're not voting in
favor for things like tax reform you you
need to be writing to them and your
specific representative because that
they're only gonna listen to you if
you're a constituent even not only
listen to you but at least you know make
a note of it and I think it is
entitlements are an important discussion
to have we can't really say we're
serious about tax reform and serious
about tackling the deficit unless you
look at government spending and the
biggest part of that is entitlement so
absolutely this needs to be part of a
giant conversation we have about big
government and government spent by the
way it is usually McCain obstructing but
I got to give it to him on tax reform he
showed I was
shocked at my chin hit the floor and the
only guy who didn't vote for it is bob
Corker I know it was really hard well
you know he'd be yesterday he tweeted
out he said or his social media intern
tweeted and said we're only 50 followers
away from three million and then all
these angry Dems unfollowed him because
of tax reform so I don't know I you know
I'm a pretty happy guy I'm pretty
grateful go over ivory followed to John
McCain because of tax reform and I'm
laughing at bob Corker I don't even care
about corker the guy's not gonna get to
be reelected anymore because he's been a
jerk for the last year that he's been in
the Senate and he voted against it when
went to bed hahaha
ladies you've made me feel better as you
always do such a delight roaming
millennial amber av thank you for being
here I'll see you again very shortly
that's our entire show today what a what
an excellent cafe show I will be back
tomorrow
get your mailbag questions in we will be
changing your life on Thursday hopefully
for the better and in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show come back tomorrow we will do it
all again
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
Hague
supervising producer Mathis Glover our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex's and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Jeshua alvera the Michael Mills show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing
2017